in the world
I'm Lee Barker in London outside the
Russian Embassy the scene of regular
protests against moscow's invasion of
Ukraine a year ago during which time
tens of thousands of people have been
killed Millions have been forced into
Exile and in the days leading up to that
key anniversary President Vladimir Putin
addressed a room packed full of Russia's
Elites he said that the Kremlin would be
pulling out of a key nuclear strategic
Arms Treaty with the U.S he also urged
Russian businesses to become more
self-reliant and accuse the west of
creating an existential threat for
Russia in the last 12 months the UK has
become one of Ukraine's most Ardent
supporters
one of Russia's fiercest critics and
alongside other NATO alliance members
has funneled billions of dollars worth
of weapons into Ukraine to help with the
nation's war effort and it's here in the
UK back in 2019 where Andre Kellen was
appointed Russia's ambassador to the UK
during that time he's faced calls to be
expelled by the former prime minister of
the UK Boris Johnson and one opposition
MP has accused him of Simply being a
parrot for Vladimir Putin's regime
Andrei Kellen Russia's ambassador to the
UK talks to Al Jazeera
Andrew Killen Russian ambassador to the
United Kingdom thank you very much for
talking to Al Jazeera
it's been a year of violent bloodshed
tens of thousands of people possibly
killed possibly Millions being forced
into Exile from Ukraine
we're talking about people living in
basements about economic instability
also Rippling around the world it's very
very hard to imagine that all of this
was in Russia's initial plan where it
began its so-called special military
operation something most other countries
simply call a war
let me bring it up up to date because
the conflict in fact did not started a
year ago it has started in 2014 when a
very nationalistic government extremely
nationalistic government in Kiev has
come to power as a result of this
revolution that is called now maidan and
the main policy or major policy of this
nationalistic government was to
exterminate Russians exterminate Russian
culture language prohibit Russian
language and even physically kill
Russians especially that are living in
the east of the country does defending
so-called Russian speakers in the
donbass also include shelling the likes
of leviv thousands of kilometers away
from Don bastards it also includes
stationing warships off the city of
Odessa thousands of kilometers away from
a donbass also sending troops into the
capital Kiev in the early days of the
war does that have anything to do with
defending as you say the rights of
Russian speakers in the donbass yeah you
know what has happened at what was
revealed by the former participants of
so-called negotiation process I mean
uh Boris Johnson as well as Francois
Hollande the former president of France
they have said that it was not only
imitation of diplomacy but at the same
time they needed to reinforce Ukraine
and to create uh out of Ukraine an
antipode of Russia a so-called
anti-russia in order to Russia has
become too strong for them so they need
a country other wheat on it and they
spent a lot of money to create out of
Ukraine very serious Fortress
full of armament what was needed one of
the goal of the operation was to reduce
the military potential of Ukraine
otherwise it was creating a very big
threat for us especially when NATO has
come to a border of Russia and they say
that probably Ukraine will be part of
NATO so we feel very threatened because
missiles that can be put on Ukraine and
installed on Ukraine territory if they
can reach Russian territory within a
couple of minutes according to the UN
Human Rights Commission more civilians
were killed since Russia's Invasion last
February that in the past eight and a
half years we're talking about something
like 8 000 civilians hundreds of
children what happened or what you
accuse Ukraine of doing and the Don bass
seems to pale in significance to what
Russia has done since last February
official figures of the United Nations
that 12 000 people has been killed from
2014 and until
2022 so it is much bigger figure these
were civilians mainly and a big part of
it that has been killed in donbass since
Ukraine has installed its Canon's
missiles uh and self-propelled Rockets
right in front of Donetsk the capital of
denbased but no evidence of so-called
genocide which is what Russian State
media repeatedly claims has happened in
the donbass according to the ofce
there's been no evidence at all of the
atrocities that Russia claims Ukraine
has carried out in the donbassador
general said it's a very specific notion
I would say it is uh it is formulated in
U.N documents and well some newspapers
and politicians using this word just
occasionally so it doesn't mean General
said in Rwanda for instance total
different thinkers when the whole
population was exterminated by those
ones so but you know said the word was
used in terms of uh inflicting a lot of
damage to civilian infrastructure and to
civilians butcher European marry Apple
you know those places very well
Ukrainian towns
where Russia's accused of all sorts of
gross atrocities and war crimes
including the murder of civilians rape
the list goes on
do you condemn these alleged crimes uh
well uh we uh he heard a lot about that
they are totally different absolutely
different things butcher has been staged
and there is no doubt about that staged
by Ukrainian special forces in Mario uh
you probably are saying about a warming
of the theater over there but victims
has not been discovered so all these
things we know but uh also when uh we
need to have a balance or we need that
International Community should be aware
of what is happening in donbass where
each day it was shelled killed and
exterminated for for instance uh do you
know that prison in Elena that contains
a lot of uh Ukrainian War prisoners was
uh damaged and destroyed by Ukrainian
missiles for instance or what was
happened in Crematory when uh the uh
well people try to leave it by train and
at the time when they're boarding the
train Ukrainian missile has exactly
result into the
train station and killed a lot of people
it's a crime but nobody is speaking
about that so you're saying that all the
evidence put forward regarding claims of
atrocities carried out by Russian forces
in the likes of Butcher and urban are
fake
in butcher absolutely it was fake in my
report has nothing to do with this
European I uh I I'm not sure about
European because I did not I'm not very
well about that so there's a possibility
that crimes may have been committed in
opinion you know this is a military
operation this is a war in fact uh
things I have civilians
are civilians collateral in that war we
do not Target especially our civilian
infrastructure it is many times has been
said that we do not Target buildings or
civilians we target sometimes energy
infrastructure because it is a command
and control system that is being used
for the military purposes so this is not
the goal at all and we are not against
the ukrainians at all but we what we
know for sure is that Ukrainian troops
they're using a civilian infrastructure
to install their military capabilities
and they are selling directly at the
Civil infrastructure and because of that
of course there's people with uh this is
military crimes a notice that you use
the word war is this a war
uh in a way yes in a way it is even you
can call it a civil war because uh on
both parts it is we do not share uh we
do not drive a line between Russian
people and Ukrainian people that
contains lots of Russia so in certain
way it is yes I'm back home in Russia
itself
those people who protest who are against
this war for whatever reason
how should they be treated
differently that depends uh is I do
recognize that not everybody is will be
is in favor of what is happening over
the year of course some are
just discussing it some are very active
but uh well in any country which is
involved in the war it has happened in
the United States of course of those who
are arranging uh public protests again
against the policy of the government
they will treat it accordingly
I mean I'm not denying that injustices
may be carried out in other countries
including the United States but focusing
purely on Russia is it right to lock up
people for substantial amounts of time
for protesting against what's going on
well you know what it is for us it is a
very special period of time and because
of that special laws has been adapted by
our Parliament which in fact uh do not
favor uh if there will be an organized
uh political process against the action
of the government it has happened in
every government if you look at what is
happening in Kiev then no one can say
anything about actions that the
opposition is totally exterminated
newspapers those are opposing the
government and political parties they
simply do not exist anymore do they
exist in Russia if they do sure of
course we have several parties that are
they have a place in Duma do you have a
plurality do you have a variety of
voices in the media particularly when it
comes to those who don't degree with
what the government and what the Kremlin
is doing well I'm seeing it every day I
wish I could press on television every
day much more than the than of the
British television now because British
television is producing only one point
of view and the debate that are taking
place uh or in our uh
talk uh political talks that are
plurality or views different views I
would should say that are being
expressed I want to be for a little bit
a bit and ask you whether you personally
were aware of the kremlin's plans for a
full-scale assault on Ukraine last
February no I was not aware of that
you've lost potentially thousands of
troops many of them former prisoners
freed to fight on the front line not to
mention many senior generals you've been
hit by wave after wave of international
sanctions and the war appears to have
strengthened not weakened NATO with the
likes of Finland and Sweden now poised
to join the alliance it's hard to
imagine that any of this was part of the
plan for Russia I don't believe that I
have a fair answer or a straight answer
to that because your question is very
complicated I'm not going to speculate
about how many lives has been lost on
one side or the other side the
calculation is that if experts uh
difference uh mainly they are saying
that we have lost on one Russian soldier
a seven or six or seven ukrainians
because uh because of all of that
yes it is difficult of course but the
price is that tag on it at the price of
what is going on and uh I would I'm not
speaking about the victory or something
like that but the price is very high on
it uh it is also confirmed by what
message does it send to the world that
Russia is using conscripts people in
prison to send to the front line to
fight on behalf knew of this kremlin's
war well I'm not going to speak a little
bit about the motives but uh the of
those as I understand I'm not fully
aware of the situation but we have a
regular army and we have a uh how it is
called private uh private companies that
also exist in the west with a variety of
them black waters for instance and all
of that all that stuff French Foreign
Legion uh
take French Foreign Legion which
consists of by the way those who have
been convicted and then going to fire it
I'm not sure about black Waters but I do
believe black Waters is also American
company a famous one that contains a lot
of those who have been sentenced and
then inscribed into this for for us uh
this uh Wagner company is a private
company and uh the issue was that
they're going to fight for some time for
for money and after uh six months if I'm
not mistaken uh they will be free they
will be free and uh relieved of these
sentences but that simply isn't the case
is it I mean we're talking about large
numbers of casualties amongst these
people
who've been recruited by Wagner this
private company with clear links to the
Kremlin to fight this conflict who is
really fighting this wall
or is it the Russian military is it the
question or a statement
I'm asking you who is fighting this war
the Russian military uh well he's
winning this war I'm I'm not uh I will I
am not in possession of all the facts it
is it's a it is uh the there is an
official uh report every day there are a
lot of bloggers who I have I I hear
different uh points on view on that and
this I think it's a combination of it it
is we are using the means that are
disposal
why does Russia continue to see the NATO
alliance a partnership of independent
Democratic states and security Alliance
why does Moscow continue to see that as
a threat an existential threat oh my God
that's a good question you know I have
spent 10 years in the headquarters of
nature trying to re to establish good
relationship between NATO and Russia but
it was all until NATO has started
bombardments of Yugoslavia where they
have killed lots of people destroyed
lots of bridges use uranium as limited
steel diseases are spread over the year
then NATO has attacked
Iraq and destroyed Iraq and the Falls
totally false pretext of an existed a
possession of uh
mass destruction weapon then was lever
which has also has been destroyed uh
totally by native forces and still there
is no State neither in Iraq proper
States other countries there some of
those countries may have had close
diplomatic ties to Russia but I'm
talking specifically about Russia
Vladimir Putin your boss has repeatedly
accused NATO of trying to encircle
Russia is that the case do you really
believe that that is the case and
absolutely it has happened we have good
promises in the end of the 90s that NATO
is not going to enlarge these promises
has been fixed on paper but whenever uh
we would take it as a treaty this
promises has been violated has been uh
destroyed we have seven waves of
enlargement of NATO closer and closer to
our borders until it has come absolutely
in the case of Ukraine towards our
border and only six percent of Russia
actually touches NATO countries Russia
has land borders with 14 countries only
five of those are NATO members where
does this narrative
of encirclement come from who does it
serve to continually insist that that is
the case that that is the goal for the
the NATO alliance no uh if your question
is about whether needs need is defensive
organization or uh aggressive
organization right now NATO and the
European Union are supplying lots of
weapon into Ukraine
let me finish please it's an important
it's an important point it's an
important point it is not only Ukraine
and Russia that are in Conflict now we
are in conflict with nature since NATO
is providing weapons for free to Ukraine
supporting a lot of money to eat and
Ukrainian and we know that lots of
forces also mercenaries from NATO
countries are participating in it in
training and as well so it is involved
right now into this conflict I want to
talk specifically about those weapons
how might the supply for instance of
Tanks long-range weapons and possibly
even fighter jets change Russia's
chances on the battlefield
don't believe that it will be a much of
an influence on that because of the
quantities I don't believe that it will
be a serious threat to us the threat is
a long-range weapon because a long-range
weapon they can achieve goals on the
territory of Russia so far other
countries abstained from uh provision or
saying that they are going to stay only
the United Kingdom is saying directly
that it is going to provide a long range
weapon for the Ukrainian Army
and we are certain that this long-range
weapon will be used against civilian
targets do you fear those weapons may be
used against Russia directly yes
how tactically might Russia respond
would that mean having to make greater
advances to push further into Ukraine
exactly you have answered your own
question then we have to move this line
further deeper into Ukraine just to
avoid a further threats to the territory
of Russia and to the territory of Denver
so by in this way uh Western countries
they are destroying Ukraine itself
is China offering Military Support to
you
officially China is saying that it is
not providing US Military Support as far
as you know as far as I know it does not
happen but we have a lot of trade with
Shane of course we must be happening
artificially I don't know no I I haven't
seen that and I do not try to attach to
me anything this Chen is saying that uh
it is not supplying us with arms and we
have no confirmation that we are getting
cars from China is there any situation
I'm sure you've been asked this many
times before whether Russia would
consider using nuclear weapons in the
battlefield I have been many times asked
about this and I can tell you once again
that our military Doctrine it envisages
only two options for the use of military
weapons if we are under severe attack by
nuclear weapons from the outside in this
case by Western countries or there is
such a conventional threat to Russia
that such a conventional Invasion into
Russia that can that can make a threat
to existence of this state this is not
the type of a conflict when we can it
can be used President Biden has said
Vladimir Putin's made a big mistake by
suspending the new start nuclear arms
reduction treaty with the US that caps
the number of nuclear weapons both
countries that have you know all too
well about this having worked in that
field yourself does Russia now plan to
use this as an opportunity to build up
its nuclear Arsenal you know and once
again know uh the issue is that uh the
goal uh that has been proclaimed by the
United States is to strategically
strategically defeat Russia in this
situation of course we cannot stick to
the uh this treaty uh but it has been uh
also stated absolutely that uh
verification mechanism is going to be
abolished right now suspended I would
say inspections and all of that stuff
but as foreign
possibly Russia would be willing to
rejoin under what conditions
rejoin the treaty the start treaty it
might happen if a United States will
change its goal uh to defeat Russia
strategically
your
your Russian ambassador to the United
Kingdom we've seen the Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski come here
several times on many high-profile
visits he's addressed nearly every
government in Europe and many
governments further afield how does that
make you feel
no it is just going with extended hand
all around the world and demanding money
demanding weapon demanding help uh this
is funny of course but it is uh does not
contribute to its image of a serious
politician it means that Ukraine has no
means either to exist economically or to
fight itself without external help it is
now totally dependent on the outside
assistance outside money the state does
not function can you explain to me why
the Kremlin has repeatedly called
Vladimir zielinski a Nazi I haven't
heard that Kremlin is uh is ever used
this term in Ukraine there are a number
of
neo-fascist organizations that is true
and the government of Ukraine as I said
it is extremely nationalistic extremely
nationalistic to draw a line between
Fascism and nationalism is extremely
difficult nine months before the
conflict began your boss President
Vladimir Putin published an essay in
which he said that Russians and
ukrainians are are one people and that
true sovereignty he said in Ukraine is
Possible only in partnership with Russia
does Putin have Imperial Ambitions to
reclaim Land Lost after the collapse of
the Soviet Union
uh well you know we uh
we do not fight against Ukrainian people
we do not fight even against Ukraine
itself I have seen many extreme
exaggerations about our goals which has
nothing to do with reality we have a
problem with uh with the government in
Kiev in fact as I described it and it
has been intention to conquer other
things we do not conquer we do not
intend to do this what has been uh
assigned to us as our probable position
it is just invention of the politicians
or some journalists
Anglo-Saxon journalism in fact has lost
its uh good qualities of serious
analysis they are now mostly running
after Sensations then uh they're trying
to analyze the real situation where do
you see the Diplomatic initiative lying
which countries do you trust to act as
potential mediators to about an end to
these hostilities it is not the question
of who is going to mediate right now
Ukrainian president zielinski has made a
decree that he is not going to negotiate
with Russia when the storms are actually
it makes it impossible for him he just
got this law through the Parliament and
he prohibited himself to do this
well he's made a very clear set of
Demands and one of his biggest demands
is that Russia completely withdraws from
all of Ukraine's territory is that
something Russia would even contemplate
no we it is absolutely uh unrealistic
because if Russia is going to withdraw
he will continue just to exterminate
Russians from its to throne of this
territory Ambassador my very last
question to you you've made a successful
career of Building Bridges between
Russia and other countries and now this
near daily weekly protests outside the
Russian Embassy is it really worth it
as for the process protest outside our
Embassy is is just I think that they are
paid and some most of the time there are
no protests so if people would like to
do this they can express this opinion
you know that we are not hostile towards
the West at all uh whether in a way to
West one is a West that has Traditional
Values uh which that has very rich
culture that is uh a lot of ties with
Russia but there is also a different
waste which is neoliberal which is very
aggressive which is try to impose its
own values which is try to dictate to
every state how to behave so this West
is not acceptable to us Andre Kellen
Russian ambassador to the United Kingdom
many thanks for talking to us
okay thank you very much
foreign